AMERICANS ON AMERICAN SOIL, A
DEFINITE DEMONSTRATION OF NAVY
MEDICINE ON BEHALF OF OUR
COUNTRY.
.
JEDEDIAH: WE’LL BRING IN DR.
SEGAL.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE IMPACT
OF THESE SHIPS, THE MERCY, THE
COMFORT, AND WHAT KIND OF EFFECT
THEY WILL HAVE IN TERMS OF THE
ABILITY OF THESE HOT SPOTS TO
DEAL WITH THE DISEASE?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, AS THE
PRESIDENT JUST SAID, THE UNITED
STATES NAVY SHIP "COMFORT," A
THOUSAND-BED HOSPITAL WITH 12
OPERATING ROOMS, ICUs, RADIOLOGY
SUITES, LABS, 5,000 UNITS OF
BLOOD IS GOING TO BRING HERE A
SPIRIT OF COURAGE, UNITED STATES
MILITARY, OF HOPE, AND
ASSISTANCE, AND IT’S GOING TO
MEAN THAT NON-COVID PATIENTS,
PATIENTS THAT DON’T HAVE THIS
VIRUS WILL BE ABLE TO GET
TRAUMATIC SERVICES, EMERGENCY
AND URGENT SURGERIES AND CARE
OUTSIDE OF THE HOSPITALS IN NEW
YORK CITY WHICH WILL FREE THEM
UP, JEDEDIAH, TO FOCUS IN ON NOT
JUST CARE FOR THE VIRUS PATIENTS
BUT TO SEPARATE THEM OUT
PROPERLY, OBSERVE PROPER
INFECTIOUS PRECAUTIONS, AND TO
GET OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
PROPERLY OUTFITTED.
THAT WILL TAKE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PRESSURE OFF AND WE’RE
ALL GOING TO BE INSPIRED TO SEE
THE SHIP COME HERE TOMORROW
.
JEDEDIAH: CAN I HAVE JUST ONE
FOLLOW-UP QUESTION, DOCTOR.
PETER HAD ASKED EARLY TO ANOTHER
GUEST ABOUT THE CONCERN THAT
SOMEONE WITH CORONAVIRUS COULD
POTENTIALLY GET ON ONE OF THOSE
SHIPS.
OBVIOUSLY THOSE SHIPS ARE
DESIGNATED FOR NON-CORONAVIRUS
PATIENTS.
DO YOU THINK THEY ADEQUATELY
WILL BE ABLE TO PREVENT THAT?
THAT’S MY FIRST THOUGHT,
UNCLEAR SYMPTOMS, HAS NOT HAD A
TEST, GETS INTO THE SHIP AND
THEN SUDDENLY YOU HAVE
CORONAVIRUS SPREADING ON THE
SHIP.
THAT WOULD BE A HUGE PROBLEM.
>> THERE’S TWO THINGS THAT COME
TO MIND.
FIRST IS THE WORD TRIAGE.
THEY SHOULDN’T BE BRINGING
PATIENTS TO THAT SHIP THAT HAVE
VIRAL OR RESPIRATORY OR SYMPTOMS
THAT COULD BE CHRONE.
IT SHOULD BE FOR THINGS LIKE
BROKEN BONES, FOR SURGERIES, NOT
FOR THAT.
THE SECOND THING THAT’S RELATED
TO THAT IS I REALLY WANT THIS
AVID HAS MADE THAT WE REALLY CAN
TEST PEOPLE WITHIN FIVE MINUTES
TO SEE IF THEY HAVE IT OR NOT.
WIDESPREAD USE OF THAT RIGHT
AWAY.
PETE: CAN’T GET ON THE SHIP ’TIL
YOU TAKE IT, MIGHT BE THE WAY TO
DO IT.
NEW YESTERDAY, POTENTIALLY THE
PRESIDENT MAY TAKE A STEP TO DO
AN ENFORCEABLE QUARANTINE OF NEW
YORK, NEW JERSEY, AND
CONNECTICUT.
LATER IN THE DAY THE PRESIDENT
CLARIFIED.
HERE’S PART OF THE TWEET THAT HE
SENT OUT ABOUT THE MOVE THEY’RE
MAKING.
HE SAID, "ON THE RECOMMENDATION
OF THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE AND UPON CONSULTATION
WITH THE GOVERNORS OF NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, AND CONNECTICUT I’VE
ASKED THE CDC TO ISSUE A STRONG
TRAVEL ADVISER TO BE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE GOVERNORS,
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE FEDERAL
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, A QUARANTINE
WILL NOT BE NECESSARY.
THE CDC FOLLOWED UP WITH PER
HOUR DIRECT GUIDELINES.
THIS IS WHAT IT SAYS.  "DUE TO
THE EXTENSIVE TRANSMISSION OF
COVID-19 IN THE AREA, C.D.C.
URGES RESIDENTS OF NEW YORK, NEW
JERSEY, AND CONNECTICUT TO
REFRAIN FROM NONESSENTIAL
DOMESTIC TRAVEL FOR 14 DAYS
EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY.
DOCTOR, YOUR REACTION, IS A
TRAVEL ADVISORY RIGHT NOW THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO, AND WHAT IMPACT
WILL IT HAVE?
>> I THINK IT’S HUGELY IMPORTANT
PETE, RIGHT NOW WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT THERE’S 52,000
CASES IN NEW YORK STATE ALONE,
AND THAT ALSO HAS ADDITIONAL
CASES IN THE OUTLYING AREAS,
WHAT WE CALL THE TRI-STATE AREA
-- NEW YORK, CONNECTICUT, AND
NEW JERSEY.
WE NEED TO CLAMP DOWN ON TRAVEL
AND REALLY RESTRICT PEOPLE,
STAYING AT HOME, SHELTERING IN
PLACE, VERY CAREFUL TRAVEL FOR
ONLY ESSENTIAL MEANS.
BUT WE NEED IT FOR ESSENTIAL
MEANS TO KEEP WHAT’S LEFT OF OUR
IMPORTANT.
I THINK THE RIGHT DECISION WAS
MADE.
STRICT TRAVEL ADVISORIES.
AND I WOULD URGE EVERYONE WHO’S
WATCHING US TO FOLLOW THEM,
BECAUSE WE DON’T NEED MORE CASES
RIGHT NOW.
OUR HOSPITALS HERE IN NEW YORK,
FOR EXAMPLE, ARE COMPLETELY
.
GRIFF: WELL, DR. SEGAL, ALL OUR
VIEWERS APPRECIATE WHAT YOU AND
THE OTHER DOCTORS WITH ARE DOING
ANSWERING QUESTIONS FROM OUR
VIEWERS.
WE HAVE A QUESTION FROM DAN.
LET’S SEE IF YOU CAN ANSWER THIS
37 HE SAYS, IS IT TRUE INDOOR
HUMIDITY CAN INCREASE THE
TRANSMISSION?
>> EXCELLENT QUESTION.
THERE WAS A STUDY FROM THE
C.D.C., CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL, BACK IN 2013 THAT DID
SHOW THAT HUMAN AIR INDOORS
INCREASES HOW FAR RESPIRATORY
DISEASES CAN TRAVEL SO I THINK
IT’S A GOOD IDEA THAT YOU HAVE
HUMID AIR, A HUMIDIFIER IN YOUR
HOUSE RIGHT NOW.
IT’S NOT A CURE ALL BUT WE FEEL
IT’S A POSITIVE STEP.
HUMID AIR OUTSIDE WILL HELP
DECREASE THE SPREAD OF THIS.
WE’RE HOPING SPRING WILL BRING
.
JEDEDIAH: WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM ELIZABETH ON FACEBOOK.
IF PEOPLE ARE SMOKING OR VAPING,
DOES THE SMOKE THEY EXHALE CARRY
THE VIRUS?
>> SO THAT’S ANOTHER EXCELLENT
QUESTION FROM OUR PRODUCERS.
I DON’T THINK SO.
BUT I’LL TELL YOU SOMETHING.
I’LL TELL YOU WHY I DON’T THINK
SO.
BECAUSE IT’S NOT AIRBORNE.
IT’S A RESPIRATORY DROPLET.
SO IT SHOULDN’T TRAVEL ON VAPOR
SMOKE.
IT’S A RESPIRATORY DROPLET ONLY.
IT’S NOT HOVERING IN THE AIR
OVER YOU.
BUT I WANT EVERYONE OUT THERE TO
KNOW THAT VAPING AND SMOKING
DAMAGES YOUR LUNGS IN WAYS THAT
MAKE IT MORE LIKELY THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE A SERIOUS CASE.
NOW IS THE TIME TO QUIT, NOT
TOMORROW.
NOW.
IT WILL HELP -- IF YOU, GOD
FORBID, GET THIS, YOU WOULD
LIKELY HAVE A MILDER CASE.
PETE: ONE MORE QUESTION EMAIL
FROM JACK SAYS, CAN THE NEW
FIVE-MINUTE TEST YOU TALKED
ABOUT, DOCTOR, FOR COVID-19 BE
ADAPTED TO THE-DRIVE-THROUGH
PROCESS SO PEOPLE FIND OUT RIGHT
AWAY?
>> YOU KNOW, I WILL BE TALKING
TO ADMIRAL JARRAR FROM HHS ABOUT
THIS.
I THINK THE ANSWER WILL BE YES.
THEY’LL CERTAINLY DO MORE
TESTING.
EASIER TO USE SWABS, 5 TO 13
MINUTES, SHOULD DEFINITELY BE
USED ON THOSE MOBILE UNITS WITH
DEFINITELY, AND WILL CUT DONE
DRAMATICALLY.
THOSE TESTS CAN DO 50,000
PATIENTS A DAY.
THAT’S WHAT WE NEED HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW.
IT WILL HELP SEPARATE PEOPLE OUT
WHO HAVE COVID-19 FROM THE
GENERAL POPULATION.
THAT WILL HELP TO SQUASH THIS.